هذا هو المنزل الذي كان يسكن فيه ايريك
توماس دانك كمستا جر في مجمع سكني في
ليبيريا وقع جميع جيرانه تحت الحجر الصحي
فلا يسمح لهم بمغادره مجمعهم السكني لكن
كان في استطاعتنا القدوم اليهم طالما
حافظنا على مسافه امنه بيننا وبينهم دانكن
كان يستاجر غرفه من منزل مارلين ويليامز
اخبرتنا خاله ويليامز انها كانت في الشهر
السابع من حملها عندما انهارت في احد
الايام فسارع جميع الجيران والاهل
مساعدتها وقد كان دانكن واحدا منهم والان
قد اظهر والده ويليامز نتيجه ايجابيه لمرض
فيروس ايبولا ويتحملان بالتالي مسؤوليه
اصابه دانكن بالفيروس الذي نقله لاحقا من
لايبريا الى
امريكا هذا الباب ورائي هو باب الغرفه
التي كان يسكن فيها دانكن مكان على صله
بالذعر الكبير الناجم عن امكانيه انتشار
المرض حول العالم هذه الغرفه بقيت تماما
كما تركها دانكن في ذلك اليوم الذي ركب
فيه الطائره متوجها الى الولايات المتحده
تيتي ويليامز في الثانيه عشره من عمرها
بمساعده دانكن الاسبوع الماضي هرعت لمد يد
العون لشقيقتها التي كانت على فراش الموت
لم يتخيل حجم العواقب التي قد تنتج عن ذلك
لا سيما دانكن حين توجه الى طائرته مغادرا
نحو امريكا بدون اي تفكير هل كان دانكن
يعلم انها تموت من
ايبولا لا لم يكن
يعلم الاسئله التي يطرحها رئيس فرقه الحد
من انتشار فيروس ايبولا على تيتي لا تبدو
انها قاربت على
الانتهاء مهمه لا يحسد عليها فهو يحاول
تعقب اثر كل من كان له صله
بمثلين حيث يؤكد لنا المسؤول ان اكثر من
100 شخص تم تصنيفهم حتى
الان تسعه اخرون ممن كان لهم علاقه بيليم
ز ماتو او هم على وشك
الموت مورسي البالغه من العمر تسع سنوات
يعتني بها شقيقها البالغ من العمر 17 عاما
في حين ان والدتهما كانت من ضمن الاشخاص
الذين التقطوا فيروس ايبولا من ويليامز
خارت قواها منذ ايام معدودات واخذت لكي
تتعالج مورسي لا تعلم بعد ان بعد مغادرتنا
لهذا المكان سيخبرها احد الجيران بان
والدتها لن تعود
ابدا لقد قلنا هذا مرارا وتكرارا مهما كنت
تحب الشخص الحامل لايبو ان مهمه الاعتناء
بالمرضى تعود حصرا للسلطات الصحيه انه درس
قاس جدا
عليهم
الم